I lost you definitely sketchy because
we've got to talk about how to actually
understand correlation a filled-in
calculator but I need you you have some
dial okay so this is just an example
I'll tell you where I've got this
example in a minute but the first thing
I'd like you to do is just get the data
down okay so it's bivariate data because
why is it bivariate data for two
variables right one of the specifics
what are the chemistry I have to
remember that this is responding to me
two variables so each column here what
did each column represent what you guess
probably each one represents a single
person and they got each of their marks
right it might not be it could be
someone's marks over time which would be
somewhat disturbing but in hell okay we
don't know at the moment but it's
reasonable to assume these data point
out each individual people okay so get
the data down that's the first thing I
want you to do once you've done that we
want to get a visualization for this
just like we had before with our arm the
graph that we were looking at we didn't
know those bad words were so I'm going
to show you how to graph this because
this is pretty important you're going to
need to take the actual numbers let's
see how good my precision not that I'm
going to highlight across because this
is bivariate data you need both
variables your birth parents okay we're
going to graph this so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to head up to the top
you can see on that insert there we go
now depending on your version of Excel
this might look slightly different but
what I want you to look for is sort of
somewhere in the middle and you might
even see something that says or has the
knife on it looks like this that's
really bad the calories there we go
scatter right this is a scalloped spot
okay I've got a whole bunch of different
options for my scatter plot
I'm just going to pick the mainlanders
there we go so this is what mine looks
like at the moment I'm going to make a
bigger I'm going to fiddle around with
it can you raise your hand for me if you
get in if you drop that go in there yes
excellency so you're with me now so
you're going to do that's going to make
that a bit bigger just that you can see
it round one
okay so stay with me okay I'm just going
to make this a bit darker okay now you
can see I've got my set of data to you
it's skewed very highly towards the top
right why does that why do I have no
data towards the left bottom because
their score is the lowest score I see
there is 48 right it's just below 50% so
that's why everything's skewed towards
the right hand side let's change that so
it's a little easier to read I want you
to follow with me if you click on these
numbers over here this axis okay
make sure the axis itself the numbers
are selected by go from 0 to 90 if you
right click on that man that's cool I
guess the resolutions quite high right
down the bottom you should see come into
this format axis okay so we're going to
change what's happening on those
vertical numbers
what's the quickl that I've got a venue
over here on the right hand side maybe
you've got a whole new dialog box that's
come up that's what my laptop is like
this it's all done the number we're
looking for over here in under access
options you see that there are bound
census boundaries top and bottom they're
currently 0 and 90 do you see that can
you give me a suggestion for what we
should change that minimum - this is the
vertical axis if I went do it to 100 I
get this is a percentage that's kind of
nice but what I really like is to make
this visit visualizations show my data
more clearly now because there are a
whole parts of the data that I can't see
or rather than aren't include on the set
I'm actually going to enrich them I'm
going to change the middle to 40 I don't
have any scores below 40 okay so if I
make my minimum 40 I'll leave my maximum
what it is if I hit enter
do you see what happens so I've just
chopped off the bottom okay I don't have
the bottom of the graph anymore or
rather the bottom starts much higher up
I want to point out if we were drawing
this by hand
we would do something to indicate that
we no longer start at zero right so you
have e0 there but then what do I have
down the bottom here yeah it's like a
little jagged line because otherwise
that's a misleading graph it sort of
betrays much big difference that is
actually there do the same thing for the
horizontal axis what value should I
choose for me I'm going to click on the
line right click to fall down access
hole is the suggestion for 40 or 50
however if I do new 40 I notice then it
makes it am
it's supposed to be a square grid that's
reasonably 100 okay so this is enough
for us to our starter actually get to
the next part I just want you to look at
this and I want you to think about what
you would guess the correlation
coefficient might be okay can you
imagine that line of best fit
going through firstly is it positive
correlation or negative correlation it's
positive actually that should have been
my first question that should not the
second question my first question is is
it correlate at all but I think if you
can see it is it's positive to would you
call out or hide under or ledyba DB is
close to 1 or close to zero out of the
two if I only gave one zero one we know
it's somewhere in the middle Ouiser
question zero one one
I think it's closer to one zero zero
would be not irrational as much okay I
think we can all see it's very pretty
high so now we're actually going to work
out what the actual value is okay so at
this point I need you to get your
calculator out again just like when we
did standard deviation in quartiles and
all that kind of thing I'm doing this on
a plus to the top yeah I'm going to give
you the heads up now I have got this on
a plus one oh so if you don't have the
same calculators
Josie's appear there might be some
slight differences then Alaskans we
looked at that
so the cavity the very very first thing
you should do if you don't use your
calculator for a while is I would invite
you actually reset everything that's
what I would advise because you never
know when like there's some extra data
it's going to tuck in there and it's
been saved from a previous time and you
go on to my couple calculations so if
you kind of fireball ships nine will get
you to the clear menu we want to clear
everything yeah okay we're good to go so
now that we've wiped it clean now we're
going to change it to stat mode so I'm
going borrowed and to to stat I cannot
pause every other time we've done this
before we've always just said one
because we've only ever been dealing
with a single variable but we are not
dealing with a single variable anymore
we are using bivariate data now it
unfortunately is not super obvious you
look at this bivariate data is option
two
okay now I actually wonder if you
remember when we talk about straight
lines like corner geometry and that sort
of thing okay we say straight lines are
in lots of different forms one of the
forms looks a heck of a lot like option
two right you'd probably say y equals MX
plus B the same idea the a and the B I
just our variables they're just got
different labels so go ahead and hit two
and magically you've got my varies are
not to be confused with what you've got
the single variable and frequency okay
so we sort she calls it that before this
is still two columns how can I tell this
is bivariate data but unless it says why
not frequency okay okay we have two data
to putting q okay now I've actually just
got rid of
[Music]
if you've got your computer there then
you can take that same set of values I
think there's fine for physics and five
for chemistry go ahead and input them
let's make physics the axes and
chemistry the wine so if you go 75 for
the first one and then you can equals
it'll take you down the column so you're
putting in all the X values once you put
in the line x value tech equals you're
going to need to use your arrows to come
all the way back up go to the right
column and then select your arm or input
rather your Y values have you got your
10 data points in it or five guys words
with ten values so now for your call I'm
going to get out of that take the data
away now to get to the actual variables
and what happened okay you may recall
we're going to ship and then which
button we looking for one one very good
but what's this that one that menu you
want fight okay I was going to go
through every single one wasn't it okay
and remember what letter I told you the
correlation coefficient was if R so go
ahead and hit three and then press
equals now remember you suggested to me
it was going to be a correlation
coefficient closer to one than zero
obviously and it was pretty titled this
is a numerical measure for how tight
Awards